What do you think is the right
answer for this one, David?
So, I observe two things
are going on between A and B.
The dot in the top right
is disappearing and
the diamond is moving out and growing.
So I said that the dot would still
disappear even though it's on the other
side of the frame and
the circle that was inside
the triangle will move out and grow.
So I said the answer was 2.
Here I've drawn a connection between the
circle and the triangle, the diamond and
the circle, and the dot and
its analogous dot.
>> 2 seems to be the right answer David.
Notice that the circle in 2 is
on the left of the triangle
even though the diamond in B,
was on the right of the circle.
That is okay because the diamond
is replacing the dot here.
And similarly,
the circle is replacing the dot here.
So if the dot was in
the left of triangle here,
it makes sense to put it in
the circle and left of the triangle.
Notice the drawing and
connection between the diamond here, and
the circle here was very easy for
us to do.
But designing an agent that make
that kind of connection is much more
difficult.
So we'll deal with lots of methods,
to help agents make what are very
natural conclusions for us.
>> This of course raises another issue.
How do we do it?
How do you solve the problem?
Why was it so easy for you?
Why is it so hard for A.I.?
Yet another question, when David was
trying to solve this problem, he looked
at the relationship between A and B and
then mapped it to C and some image here.
But one could have gone
about it the other way.
One could have picked any one of
these images, put it in the D and
asked whether this would be a good fit.
So in one case, one can start from
the problem and propose a solution.
In another case, one can take one
of these solutions at a time,
put it here and see whether it matches.
Two different strategies.